هذا صحيح ، كان هناك بالفعل قدر
كبير من الدراما العالية على الأقل بالمعايير الصينية
أه خلال الحفل الختامي
في مقاطع الفيديو والصور ، رأينا بالفعل
الزعيم الصيني السابق هوجينغ تاو ،
وهو سلف السيد شي ، لقد تم السماح له بالخروج
من الغرفة أه برفقة اثنين
الموظفون الذكور في منتصف هذا
الحفل الآن الذين شوهدوا وهم يجرون محادثة قصيرة
مع الرجلين
ويبدو أنه تم السماح لهم بالخروج على مضض
وقبل ذلك بدا أيضًا أنه أجرى
محادثة قصيرة مع شي جين بينغ ثم
ربت على كتف  الدوري الممتاز
في طريقه للخروج الآن بسبب الطبيعة الغامضة
للسياسة الصينية لسنا
واضحين بشأن الظروف
المحيطة بهذه
اللحظة المفاجئة للغاية أه المفاجأة وفي الواقع أه
إعلام الدولة هنا قد أبلغ عن هذا على
الإطلاق وبمجرد أن بدأنا الحديث عن
هذا  منعت أجهزة الاستشعار الصينية
إشارة CNN هنا في الصين ، لكنها مجرد
لحظة غير متوقعة في هذا
الحدث المصمم بشكل كبير في العادة